[Music]
good morning everyone my name is reto
Meier I'm a developer advocate here at
Google now technically I'm a DDA on the
Google cloud devrel team so if if any of
you bump into my boss or I mean really
anyone from the Google cloud team and
they ask how the presentation went if
you could tell them that I presented how
to build a cloud back-end for your
mobile app that would really help me out
now what I am presenting is hopefully
what everyone is here to see is android
protips a fresh look at expert advice
for advanced Android developers as the
title suggests this will be a very
technical talk there will be a lot of
code if you're not comfortable with code
or if you came to hopefully see the
Grateful Dead you are in the wrong place
you're also about twenty years late now
just to get a feel for to make sure we
do have the right people in the audience
how many of you are developing for
Android right now me not now now but
like at home and at work okay most of
you not everyone that's cool like this
um Android curious folks here some dead
heads in the wrong place and time I
think there's some folks up on the bank
just working on their town and that's
cool too everyone's welcome
thank you for coming now this is
actually a pretty special year for
Android this marks the 10 year
anniversary of Android development super
exciting obviously not everyone's been
developing on Android for quite that
long how many have you been developing
for more than two years yeah Wow
most five years a few hands down what
about ten years do we have any ten year
veterans a few nice congratulations
yeah round of applause for the ten years
I do have that honor that privilege of
having been developing for Android for
ten years I even brought receipts this
is my very first question on Stack
Overflow it's asking about the Maps API
for the point 9 beta SDK which those
handful of 10 year veterans will
hopefully remember maybe hopefully not
remember this is not my first Google i/o
this is not my first pro tip session so
I'm curious and this will be the last
question I asked for a little while at
least how many of you have been to a
previous i/o and seen one of my previous
pro tip sessions that's a decent handful
alright and you still came to this
that's that's reassuring so thank you
for that uh-hum I actually spent a fair
bit of time over the last couple of
months looking back over these sessions
and at first it was because I wanted to
gain some inspiration you know like what
are the cool things we used to talk
about you know gains were the excitement
from the early days of Android but I
quickly realized that not everything
that I had said in those early days has
held up all that well so as a result
what I'm actually going to be presenting
this year is looking at all the things
that we've said in previous years and
giving it a bit of an update so there's
the real real title slide for today's
session is actually android protips
fixed
sorry so the goal here is to provide you
with all the tips and tricks and best
practices and good advice it's going to
help us develop great apps for the next
decade of android development and in
order to do that effectively I want you
to take the same journey as me so we're
going to start by going back in time
we're going to go back through previous
Google iOS previous pro tips sessions
all the way back to the very very
beginning yeah we may have gone too far
back this is me in kindergarten happy
child don't know what a fragment is and
I've never heard of a content provider
that will change also side note I didn't
know I was presenting in the
amphitheater and that there would be a
400 foot screen if I had known that I
may have included fewer pictures of
myself take note if you're ever in this
situation clearly we're too far back so
let's just bump it a few years forward I
think I can do that with one of these
buttons let's have a look yes yeah this
is more like it don't I look young this
is 2008 and I remember this because this
is actually the cover photo for my first
Android book and we took this photo just
after I'd got in the first round of
editor notes back from the first draft
and the next day and reader loosed the
1.0 SDK and up until then I'd been
writing based on the point nine theater
and I knew what was coming
you know the clue is in the name but I
figured how much is gonna change write
1.0 from point nine point eight two
point nine was pretty minor so it should
just be a couple of little things turns
out a lot can change like really a lot
I'd actually written an entire chapter
on the gtalk data API which was it was
pretty cool but it did not exist in the
1.0 SDK there's 30 pages of hard work I
didn't remove it I ended up leaving it
in the book because by the time it came
out who knows right Android moves
quickly well it's been 10 years it never
got put back in and eventually I removed
it from future revisions of the book
anyway the reason I mention this is
because I've spent most of the past 10
years going around talking about Android
giving advice on the best way of doing
things the the latest and greatest API
is that you can take advantage of to
build great apps and I do this with the
knowledge that sometimes within months
even weeks and these things are going to
change they're going to be replaced with
something more efficient more
comprehensive and in fact weeks and
months is a best-case scenario I
remember one particular incident I had
just finished a keynote very exciting
Google developer day in Prague I think
it was what's new in cupcake I've been
doing this for a while and I stepped off
stage and just as my foot hit the ground
we released donut so in that instance
they had about three certain nanoseconds
of being current before everything I
said was effectively outdated now
despite how all of that may sound this
is actually really a good thing well for
you not not so much for me but for you
it's a good thing this it demonstrates
how quickly Android is evolving to take
advantage of what or to give users and
developers the things that they need to
be able to be successful there's always
been a trade-off and I know you all have
felt this pain where new platform comes
out awesome new API is great new
functionality take advantage of but you
know it's going to take a while before
lots of users are on that platform and
at the same time you know some of the
older platforms are going to take a few
years before they go away so you have to
do this trade-off is it worth putting in
the time and effort to take advantage of
the new API is the new functionality
knowing that it's going to have to be
backwards compatible and you're gonna
have to maintain that code potentially
for years so when do you do that
well the thing is what we're what makes
us really excited is that now we have
jetpack alright which incorporates all
of the Android support library Android
architecture components and if you take
jetpack and combine it with Google Play
services we end up with an increasing
surface area of api's which don't rely
on having the latest platform version so
you can take advantage of the new
functionality that's available and we'll
take care of writing all of the
boilerplate code to make it backwards
compatible for you all right so this
this is a nice advantage right suddenly
that trade-off isn't quite as expensive
now it's still one of the big pluses of
this as well is that we're no longer
tied to the framework right so we can
continue to launch new features fix bugs
encapsulate more best practices take
care of more edge cases we can do all of
this in between platform releases which
is great for developers not so awesome
for those of us trying to talk about it
things change more rapidly but there's a
price right if you want to take
advantage of this cool new stuff you
have to reconsider some of the
fundamental architectural choices in how
we build our apps and so I'm going to
talk today a little bit about why I
think now is the right time to do that
if we if we bring it down to its real
fundamentals what we're trying to do is
keep our app looking fresh lightweight
full of potential if not we quickly risk
becoming visibly older outdated little
bloated may be harder to maintain harder
to manage and I know there's an analogy
for high cholesterol but I couldn't I
couldn't figure it out you get the idea
right
so before we sort of dive into some of
the tips which we do need to update I
did want to spend just a little bit of
time highlighting a handful of pro tips
which have stood the test of time that
like a fine wine or a sharp cheddar
actually aged pretty well there's
probably more than just the ones on this
list but this is the highlights and what
you'll notice about these particular pro
tips is that
not really specific to Android they're
not even really specific to mobile
development this is just good best
practice that you should always be
keeping in mind when building any
engineering app so let's not dwell too
much on the things that we know are
still good ideas let's take a look at
some of the things which have changed
which have perhaps not aged quite as
well
now everything on this list you can
pretty much still do but it's all been
replaced with newer api's that are more
efficient that encapsulate a bigger
amount of functionality
sometimes the underlying hardware's
change to the UI bear that paradigm has
changed but a lot of it you can still do
and that's actually kind of a theme for
a lot of the things that we're going to
be looking at there has always been ways
of achieving certain things but there's
now significantly better ways simpler
ways which involve less code less hacky
workarounds making it more predictable
and easier for you to maintain and
manage your code base as going forward
so we know things have changed I've said
that a few times but there's certain
things we've always been able to rely on
right you write your Android code in
Java language syntax and all of the
application components are basically the
same we use the same core components
they interact the same way they achieve
the same end results and that's
something we've been able to rely on
until basically until now the last year
or so things have fundamentally changed
Android studio 3 introduced Kotlin as a
first-class language for Android
development and that's actually what
we're encouraging people to use as their
primary development language for Android
we saw the introduction of Android
architecture components which introduced
view models live data and the room
database to significantly simplify the
way that we manage data and have it
interact properly with the activity
lifecycle we also have the job scheduler
which almost entirely eliminates the
need to create your own custom
background services and the intent
receivers that we sometimes set up to
monitor device state to control when our
services are run which is a good thing
because in Android oh we actually
the ability to have long-running
background services when your app is in
the background as well and at the same
time most of the intent receives that
you may have used to monitor device
State have also largely been deprecated
now the good thing of course things move
quickly job scheduler already deprecated
as of yesterday morning so now we have
work manager which is nice because it
does the same stuff as job scheduler but
it's backwards compatible right so
you're starting to see some of the
trends of what we're trying to achieve
here so we should dig into some of this
stuff in a little bit more detail it's
something which I've talked about it
most of these pro tip sessions was the
first thing I talked about and comes up
every year I like to to focus on what's
happening what's happening in the
background sometimes it's easy to miss
until you really focus on it so the
first pro tip I gave back in 20 2010
first session first Android session
first real session on a big stage is
very exciting and this is the first pro
tip so I thought let's have a look at
what I said and see how well it holds up
so this is this is the first thing I
ever anything which can in any way take
longer than just a fraction of a second
and interrupt the UI flow do you move it
into a background threat so there's a
number of ways you can do that the most
simple and straightforward is of course
just to use Java threading what we've
created in Android is a class called
async task
yeah you know what they say the giant
screen actually removes 20 pounds so
it's kind of Shirin right like kind of
like we don't want to block the UI
thread what the context around what I
was talking about was trying to
eliminate these application not
responding dialogues which have evolved
over the years they look a little bit
different now they used to be very
common because it was easy to block the
foreground thread right if you tried to
do a data transfer for example it would
block and that would be a bad experience
and so for Android 3.0 we introduced a
runtime exception so if you tried to
access the internet through a runtime
exception the app would crash strong
encouragement for developers to not do
that more recently we've done similar
things with filesystem access with
database access as well now in Android
pee this is no longer a problem because
we don't show an out dialogues we just
crash the app so that's not a better
outcome for your users but it's a much
stronger signal to us as developers that
we need to make sure that we're taking
care of this particular problem now I
did mention one solution and it got some
got some love the old async task it's a
reasonable solution to the stated
problem we need to move everything off
back off the foreground onto a
background thread and that's what async
task does creates a background thread
and then it has these two handlers which
are called Marshall back to the UI
thread so you can update the UI when
you've got progress or a final result to
display I would like to tell you that
the only thing missing from that is that
now you have to write it in Kotlin it's
better
Harlen looks nicer it's certainly more
concise but you still have the same
fundamental problems where if you're
doing this stuff within an activity if
the user rotates the phone it's all
gonna go wrong right your threads going
to be get killed your async task and
that's kind of your best case scenario
you may leak context you may try and
update a UI element that just doesn't
exist or is in the process of getting
killed and recreated it's problematic
now back in that first IO session I had
a solution for this
was a great solution the advice was you
should move it to a service which it's
fair to say this advice has not aged
spectacularly well now the general
principle is is still pretty reasonable
all right it's like you have something
long running so you're in your activity
you use an intent to start a service
probably an intent service and that goes
and does the time-consuming work maybe
it's pulling something down from a
server or interacting with the database
or performing some complex calculation
and when it's finished it sends an
intent back to the activity and it then
updates the UI accordingly basic stuff
and it's a reasonable approach but it
does introduce some new challenges
services are heavyweight components
right we don't really want to create
them we want to kill them as quickly as
possible to gain back some of those
system resources and they keep running
even when your activity isn't which is
kind of the point but now you have to
keep in mind your activity life cycle
what's it doing have you actually exited
the app have you transitioned to a new
activity should the service keep running
should it be canceled all of this stuff
you need to keep in mind and it's doable
it's just a lot of work to get right and
of course because services run at a high
priority it actually prevents the system
from killing your app to gain resources
if it needs to and there's no guarantee
that your service will actually keep
running if your app is force quit so
there's another problem which is in
Android oh you can't guarantee that your
background services will be running when
you want them to you can't start a
background service when your app is in
the background from a broadcast receiver
and they will be killed after a few
minutes even if they were initiated
while your activity was in the
foreground now for really time-consuming
things which you need to have run this
is still a reasonable approach you have
an activity uses a service to then
download data from a server say it's a
nice time-consuming operation and then
that saves it to a database and then
your activity just monitors the database
so it's kind of a one-way flow which is
nice but there is a catch there's
there's always a catch and the catch is
that this is not an efficient way to use
the cell radio and back into
20:12 I'm not going to go into too much
detail but I had this whole spiel about
how the cell radio works and every time
you do a transfer turns on the radio it
stays in a standby state which draws
more power and the goal is that it
reduces latency for future transfers
that's all great and the reason it's
important for us to know is that if
you're doing lots of transfers you can
keep the radio turned on it's gonna draw
power more quickly so we had some
specific advice for this which was you
should deal with that you know how it
works now efficiency is important so fix
it I had this whole metaphor to help it
was about cookies I have a friend who's
an artist and this is an excuse to get
him to draw things and the idea here was
to use the big cookie model where you're
minimizing the total number of transfers
that you're using across the app
lifecycle so if you have something
that's not time-sensitive like analytics
you cue that up and wait next time
there's an in a user initiated refresh
you send all of the cue data you also
look into the future to see is there
anything which is going to be scheduled
to happen in a few minutes and let's
just do that first so it was a way to
manually batch and bundle all of your
transfer so that they happen at the same
time and you get some increased
efficiency now as I'm sure you can
believe doing all of this and
understanding how to do it right it was
complicated enough that a room full of
Engineers much like yourselves back at
Moscone believes that this was a
legitimate equation you needed to solve
in order to figure out how to do this
right it's not this is just made up by
2012 we had a solution a solution which
was the sync adapter and the sync
adapter we claimed was pretty straight
forward which is fair to say was a lie
now it's still better than to eat all in
all yourself and once you set it up yeah
it's not that complicated right you're
able to trigger a one-off for a periodic
transfer and the sync adapter will
handle all of the background work doing
the batching and time shifting form
multiple of your requests that happen
within a sort of time window so you
don't have to think about when you
trigger it you just do and trust the
sync adapter to handle the timing for
you unfortunately to make this all work
you needed to have a sync adapter fair
enough
sync adapter runs within its own service
of course you also need to have a an
Account Manager which isn't used but
it's part of the API and the account
authenticator also needs its own service
to run in ok I'm seeing a trend you also
need to have a content provider again
doesn't need to be used but needs to
exist you do all of this right at all in
Java and then there's maybe it does an
XML files you need to write as well plus
the manifest changes and then you're
good to go you sync adapter works it's
fair to say that a lot of people trying
to make this work found it to be kind of
frustrating and of course it only
batched and bundled your app your
transfers within your own app which is
why 2013 great year Android 5 we
introduced the jobscheduler api which is
not being replaced job scheduler works
at the platform level so it does the
batching and bundling for all of the
apps at the same time to be able to take
advantage not just of cell radio battery
improvements but all of the resource
improvements that we're trying to do
things like standby and doze mode all of
this so within your app you create a new
job service that does the asynchronous
background updates in this case we're
using the async task which we can use
now because we don't have the same
memory leak problems and then within
your specific activity you just define
the criteria that you need in order for
that job to be successfully executed if
it needs to be on the internet needs to
be charging etc how urgent is it what is
your preferred timing is a periodic all
of that sort of stuff and the job
schedule then
handle all of the background work for
you in the most efficient way possible
the only thing which would be better
than the job scheduler is if it worked
in a backwards compatible way which is
why we launched work manager which is
part of jetpack now to use work manager
you it works basically the same way you
create a new worker and that is where
you're defining the background work that
needs to be done and then within your
activity you do the same thing you
specify the constraints that need to be
met before this work can be accomplished
and then work manager will handle all of
this for you in the background
same as job scheduler but it now also
encapsulate s' the best practice
solution for earlier platform releases I
think it goes back to four point four so
it'll use the latest and greatest job
scheduler if you're running on the
latest platform all the way back to
probably alarmmanager for some of the
earlier platform releases and again you
don't need to write any of that
boilerplate code for backwards
compatibility we do all of that for
years you don't have to maintain it find
the bugs find the edge cases you can
rely on work manager to take care of
that and of course this is going to
continue to improve in future releases
so as job scheduler continues to improve
on the platform work manager is going to
be able to evolve to take advantage of
some of those changes you can learn all
about work manager and stage two today
at 5:30 I recommend going along it's a
really cool new API so work manager it's
great if it's something which is
genuinely time consuming and it needs to
be initiated on the client side now one
of the things which we've always said
and which really hasn't changed is that
wherever possible you should eliminate
periodic refreshes and any updates that
need to happen based on changes on the
server side should be initiated by the
server preferably using Google Cloud
messaging by which of course I mean
flyer base cloud messaging because GCM
was deprecated in April things move
quickly now firebase Cloud messaging
takes advantage of the same scalable
reliable GCM infrastructure that we've
been using in the past but also improves
delivery reporting and reliability it
also adds a web console so you can send
notification
and to your apps without having to have
your own server instance now for
transfers this gives us a pretty good
solution but there's really no way that
this is a viable solution for being able
to maintain a small amount of data
whenever the phone rotates for that
matter using Singleton's or overriding
the application class which I may or may
not have said in previous years is
similarly considered somewhat
distasteful so which is why in android
3.0 we introduced headless fragments and
loaders assume everyone's familiar with
both of these fragments were designed to
break your UI up into chunks that were
independent reusable and interchangeable
and the key here was they were also
aware of the parent a parent activity
lifecycle now the trick with headless
fragments was that they didn't have a UI
so you could configure them to be
retained across an activity restart
based on a configuration change and this
is really nice because it meant now we
have somewhere to store our data model
that's independent of the activity being
recreated every time the configuration
changes but managing fragments was
tricky and if you attended the first
Android session this morning here you
see just how tricky it was you can add
and remove fragments from any activity
you can have multiple instances of the
same fragment within the same activity
the fragment transactions are all done
asynchronously so you can't guarantee
when something is there and it's got its
own life cycle to manage now none of
this was great right you were able to
achieve what you wanted but it was it
was complicated to make this all work
now loading loading was better
loaders made it easier to asynchrony
asynchronously load data within your
fragments and activities and then you
could observe and react to changes in
the loader within the activity based on
whatever the underlying data changed and
in most cases you had to handle all of
that plumbing yourself which meant you
needed to load the data from wherever it
was stored you needed to then a
deserve changes within that underlying
data and bubble it back up through the
loader so that you could have the simple
code in your activity which was unless
you used cursorloader now cursorloader
was great because it did most of the
work for you
you initialize the loader within the
activity or fragment at creation time
and then you just filled in a number of
callbacks to create a new cursor and
then to receive the results so that you
can update the UI accordingly
now initializing a cursor loader was
pretty straightforward you pass in the
authority of the content provider that
you want to query in the sequel
statement that you want to use to get
back your results all that gets passed
into a Content resolver because your
content provider and gets you back a
cursor which you can then use to update
UI but by definition that meant that you
needed to make your data available via a
content provider and content providers
are actually you know what I'm going to
come back to content providers I'm just
gonna leave it in there for a moment so
ok so take a step back we've got
Headless fragments and loaders and
technically that enables us to do
everything that we need to do there's a
problem though it's really hard to get
them to work together understand how to
make them work across multiple
activities and fragments and the various
different implementations of both in
fact getting it all to work reliably and
well was again it was frustrating which
is why we're also excited to see Android
architecture components Android
architecture components introduced view
models live data and the room database
and this all effectively replaces
fragments and loaders is a simple way to
separate your UI and your UI data the
view model itself is actually really
simple to create you start with a
property that stores the data that you
want to expose in this case we're using
a mutable live data that's why data is
cool and then you expose a method which
is going to return that property and so
the first time it's going to populate
that property and then from then on it
will return that cached version
then you have a method which does that
population and again this is done
asynchronously in this case again we're
using our old friend the asynchronous
task then whenever the value of your
mutable live data changes that is going
to trigger any observers that you have
attached to it so back in your activity
all you need to do is request the view
models ask for the specific view model
class that you've just created and then
call that view models data access method
which will either then populate the data
and return it either way you'd add it
observer to that and then your observed
trigger is going to get called both the
first time you attach the observer and
then any time the underlying live data
changes now the beauty of view models is
they survive activity restarts so we
don't have to deal with with that
particular scenario and beauty of live
data is that it understands the activity
lifecycle so the first time the app is
run your view model gets created
populates the live data from the
underlying data source sends the results
back via the observe handler within your
activity and then if someone rotates
their phone the activity gets destroyed
gets recreated but the existing view
model is returned the existing live data
is returned why the observe Handler and
it's triggered with the latest version
of the data whether it's been updated or
not
in the interim in fact live data is
really smart because it only sends
updates via the observe Handler when the
activity is active because you don't
need to update the activity if the UI
isn't actually visible and if there is
new so if there is new data it will wait
and then transfer it once the activity
becomes active there's a total result
what we do is we feel less like this and
much more like this which is always that
goal content providers I promised I'd
come back to content providers and just
set some context this is what happens
this is the number of students enrolled
in each of the lessons of our Android
Udacity class and as you can see the
highlighted columns of when we get to
content providers
loaders so you get the impression this
is something that people find a little
frustrating we've improved it since then
it's it's not quite so grim now and some
of what we're going to talk about now
actually explains some of those
improvements why is it so frustrating
well this is the boilerplate code for
creating a simple content provider I'm
sure many of you have built something
like this the in truth it's it's really
just the first couple of methods it it
goes on for a little while and now keep
in mind this isn't doing anything
particularly special it's just passing
content resolve requests straight
through to a sequel like database now
obviously that's just the content
provider then you need to create a
contract that defines the column names
that you want to use to be able to
interact with it
then of course you need to create your
own sequel I'd open helper which is how
you create update and access the
underlying database now all of this
operates on cursors which is probably
not what you're using in your UI so
you'll need to create a class to
represent the records in the database
which is nice it's actually quite simple
in Cortland but you'll also need code to
convert between those class objects and
content values to add rows to your
tables and you'll need to be able to
convert between cursors and lists of
your class objects somewhere along the
line you need to set up a bunch of
observers so that at the bar database
changes your list of objects also gets
updated it's a lot of code for something
which should be relatively
straightforward quick one is there
anyone here who gets paid per line of
code no okay
so if there is and you were just too shy
that old method actually works really
well stick with that for the rest of us
this is where the room database really
comes into its own so as it's part of
Android architecture components now part
of jetpack and all you need to do is you
start with the class definition right
defines the columns that you want within
your class and you just add an
annotation to say this is an entity that
I want to use in a database and this is
the primary key for this table then you
create a new room database which
includes each of the tables that you
want to have within that database and
you return an instance of the
data access object and that is the class
where you specify all of your database
interactions your inserts deletes
updates and your queries as many of them
as you want in as many different styles
as you want now you'll notice that the
the queries here return live data and
that's really cool because if you're
storing your UI data in your view model
which obviously you are cuz that's the
right way to do things now it actually
simplifies that new view model
significantly you just request access to
the room databases access object execute
the query which returns live data itself
then you just pass that live data rate
right back through to any activity or
fragment which requests it back in the
activity it works the same way you've
got the same observe handler getting the
same live data representing a collection
of objects and you can use that to
update the UI whenever the underlying
database changes so you've got the same
outcome that you did before but ten
times less boilerplate code ten times
less code that you have to maintain and
alter if you change a column name
beforehand it was a lot of places that
could go wrong now you just modify the
class now if you combine that with the
work manager you actually get a really
clean solution to this whole process
right the work manager downloads data
from a server it updates the room
database accordingly which then sends
the live data to the view model within
the activity and fragment or fragment
that you want to use which then by the
observe handler updates the UI right so
if you're not one of the lucky folks who
are still getting paid by line of code
this is probably a better solution
so speaking of better solutions what
else have we got I wanted to talk a
little bit about Android location
services because this is again the topic
that I spent a lot of time talking about
being able to find the current position
and put it on a map somewhere is
something that's been part of Android
since the very first beta SDK and so by
2011 I'd actually managed to amass quite
a collection of pro tips for how to take
advantage of the location manager in the
most efficient and effective way
possible it was a big topic in a couple
of my android protips
talks so I went to the location team
said I've built a project which
encapsulate all of our best practices
all of the things which we tell people
to do and it's fair to say that they
were impressed by which I mean it really
left an impression they they then went
away and did what they do which is fixed
everything
and so we're beforehand I had all of
these classes and interfaces they went
away and gave me an API as part of the
fused location manager use location
provider which does all the magic for
you and encapsulated all those best
practices within a small number of
simple api's all you need to do here is
tell it what's more important battery
life or accuracy how often do you want
to get results and the fused location
provider goes and does all of the hard
work for you
now now that's it things have changed a
little bit in reo we made some changes
new restrictions about how you can
receive location updates while your app
is in the background in order to save
battery life and specifically that means
that if you are in the background you
only received updates from location
manager or the FLP a few times an hour
there's a few ways that you can deal
with this right you can make a
foreground service which is what we do
with navigation another approach is to
use geo fences so for those of you who
remember the very first version of geo
fencing on Android wear proximity alerts
proximity alerts were bad easy enough to
set up specify a lat/long a radius
around a point and they would fairly
reliably trigger if you went across that
boundary now the challenge was the way
that it achieved that was by turning on
and leaving on your GPS so as long as
you had a proximity alarm set it would
keep the GPS running permanently which
is not what the documentation said but
it is what happened now luckily the same
Google Play services launched which gave
us the fused location provider also gave
us a real geofencing API had all the
functionality that was client claimed
from that was claimed to be done with
proximity alerts but also gave you a few
additional
improvements most important of which was
that it didn't keep the GPS locked
permanently on we can take our geofences
to the next level with the awareness api
which adds additional context signals
which allow us to make more complicated
fences specifically we can add date and
time proximity to beacons user activity
if they're walking cycling driving and
device state you can combine all those
conditions together such as in this
example well we have one fence which is
triggered if you drive within a thousand
meters of a given location between ten
and six we have a little bit of time
left one thing I learned in 2018 is that
there's a new way to I'm sorry that
should be there's a new way to control
media right now back in the day
controlling media playback was done with
the media player I'm going to bus
through this pretty quickly mainly it
meant that you had to listen to media
buttons getting clicked now of course
you can control media a bunch of
different ways so we've got a better
solution which is exoplayer which
effectively replaces the framework Media
Player is easy to customize and extend
again I'm not going to go through the
full details here I had a couple of
slides but I have been speaking too
slowly so I recommend that you go to
mark and Andrews talk tomorrow morning
at 10:30 to get all of the details now
not all of the changes in Android have
been include some of the biggest changes
are actually in the availability of
Android expertise back when we started
we didn't have slack and Google
developer experts we didn't even have
Stack Overflow what we did have was IRC
we had Google developer groups we had
some devrel people which spoke at
conferences and that still kind of
happens but the big change now is that
we're just voices within a much larger
developer ecosystem there are now lots
and lots of people around the world to
help each other this is just a small
selection of the 90 people developer
experts specializing in Android and
Kotlin all around the world there's just
a small amount of the extended
engineering team that we have helping
the community similarly we've got
Android conferences all around the world
this is a small selection of some of the
Android events that people pointed out
to me on Twitter a couple of weeks ago
when I asked
what the best conference is to go to war
because really the biggest tip that I
can give you is that much more than
changes in the tooling or the frameworks
or the api's or jet pack or anything
else much more than that
the biggest thing driving Android
development forward is the community
it's the people around you the people
online we're all helping each other with
Android and it's important because we
know that the one thing that doesn't
change is that things are going to
change so take advantage of things like
jetpack to make things simpler work with
the people around you and hopefully your
apps will survive much longer than my
pro tips thank you
[Applause]
[Music]